2016 is gonna be great your video games
we're all very excited about it but what
about the game is that are not gonna
make it what about the games to get
delayed games get delayed you know that
Michael Hardy I've heard they do this
lots of games from last year got delayed
until this year yeah uncharted 4
remembered i was gonna come at last year
yeah and that was March now it's April
yeah the late again who knows no man's
sky people thought for a while there my
comment 2015 nope that's what is it like
III we play yeah that's gonna be a
goddamn disaster yeah I'm of a release
day hopefully the game be good and we
just found at the scale bound which
didn't look super harsh and that's
that's been delayed for 2017 probably a
good thing Yeah right I look cool yeah I
don't have very many reasons to buy an
xbox one no don't play forza soon any
reason not Andy but I was actually
looking forward to it I mean it like you
said it kind of looked a little bit
rough on the edges but just the concept
I was like oh that's pretty cool I mean
the whole bro thing with the Dragons
kind of weird but yeah i late or someone
yeah it was a real Dante feel ya real
Dante that's why I think I was into it
cuz like I'm into DMC I was like yeah
all right I'm kind of feeling this get
dragon armor turning to like you know
but all right to 2017 I can wait another
year on xbox one work on it yeah they're
gonna skate all the dude bro that they
inserted into the game they're gonna now
like take out over the next 12 months
that's how it works and we also found it
a recourse been pushed back as well in
the long tradition of KJ nephew a delay
okay I mean mighty number 9 also didn't
come in 2015 that one's 2016 that right
like and it's like they're they're
slated yes yeah point yet which is how
they said like Christmas rq-4 or
something I think so it's later it's
like late it was at this point if I did
delay it again that would just be I
wouldn't be but I won't be surprised no
we decided on that game no like we've
seen like a was it a traitor was that
even gameplay I don't very brief
glimpses if any since so we and it's you
have to say as well with like my
denominators coming out now februari 9th
is current age and they've like I know
he's like working on these projects
maybe he's not like super involved in
some of them but you got an like a one
and i was getting pushed back then you
got to think it's having
like a domino effect on all the other
project so we'll see but I want to look
at the list of the other big games are
coming into some kind of one's here that
have either been delayed a lot or you
could seating at in push back and kinda
like gauge your guys's thoughts on
whether or not we will see this stuff
push back into 2017 first one quantum
breaks been like common air forever
april fifth and it's coming out do you
think we're past the point where remedy
can like have that thing slip again mike
i would think so yeah I be surprised if
they delayed it once more there maybe
maybe once more but I'm pretty positive
we'll see in the spring just because
everything we've seen of it they've been
showing us gameplay now at this point it
looks polished I mean I've been plated
no I played it as well yeah so they have
had bills out there did it like feel
complete yeah it felt like okay it felt
like a good vertical slice like this is
done it looks polished right now and it
looks it looks like it's ready and I
don't know that I'm terribly excited for
it but it looks like it would be able to
come out in April because how many
delays have they had so far with alcohol
I feel like three or four right I'm kind
of a different game because I had all
that weed TV stuff going on when
Microsoft was in the day like that's how
far we're going back on this we're
talking Don Mattrick era was when they
were like talking about it and kind of
on the other side of that then a game
that we haven't heard a lot of bad
that's coming out pretty close after its
launch Far Cry primal currently sated
for februari 23rd Eric which do you
think people would mind if that got
pushed back um I mean I don't think
they'd mind that much but I think that
it's probably gonna make it state or
something close to it because you know
that beta or whatever that that gameplay
that we were able to see I think it was
IPS X as well yeah it looked pretty done
and there's no multiplayer you know
component to it so it it looks like it's
ready you know like um when February's a
good month right like you know there's
not that much stuff happening in the you
know first quarter of the year like why
not bring on a new Far Cry game like a
lot of people like for a car for right
and now you get to tame you can be the
beast man and it's been a while it's far
cry 4 was like November 2014 so it but
it kind of felt like it was pretty close
behind it but I guess it's been enough
time presumably if that team was also
like shifting on to primal I'm everyone
primal was first announced we were
wondering if it's more of a Blood Dragon
situation more just like the kind of I
guess in the grand scheme you think a
bite-sized kind of far
crying but it seems sizable and I
actually get to play it sometime soon
next weekend really review so I'm eager
to see it because I haven't touched it I
didn't get the chance to play it at PSX
yet so is that stuff gonna be super
embargoed probably yeah probably i think
it's like a week after work okay so soon
check back in a fortnight yeah we'll
find out two weeks if it's good we'll do
next week okay you can do that another
one that this is kind of a strange one
because I feel like it could really go
either way depending on not really
anything to do with their hard with the
game itself maybe the hardware the we
you obviously had a difficult year last
year had some pretty good games come at
actually for it didn't sell very well at
all and obviously the departure of
owatta is going to be take a massive
effect on their whatever plans they had
as well and the NX was already slated
for going to be announced or shown maybe
this year there's a vague sort of cloud
hanging over this Zelda project we've
only seen that trailer it looks really
good it's been a while since we've seen
any more of us they were already kind of
being a little bit secretive with the
information with there's a weird video
where it was on the TV behind them and
stuff my mic first of all do you think
we'll see Zelda next year do you think
it's going to be one of these you know
cross-platform cross-generational games
like like what was the gamecube one
twilight princess was it like a man on
but on wii and gamecube what do you
reckon i think it will be um I they've
you know they said last year I think
this is they're going to say like what
this means to be a hybrid I you know
play console mobile platform hmm and I
think they have to if they're gonna
bring out Zelda sometime it's when
you're trying to like you know pump up
the NX whatever it happens to be because
you know like toilet princess I still
consider it game huge white sounded like
you said toilet princess which sounds
like pretty better game yeah toilet
princess I considered a gamecube title
but then once Skyward Sword came out on
the is exclusively for the wii and that
was like the defining game on the wii
for me yes so I'm wondering if they have
to kind of sacrifice maybe just my
closed yeah maybe cuz notnot overall
quality but I feel like it might feel a
little more like a port between two
consoles I think that'd be worth it to
try to push the NX so we'll see and I
hate to say that just because I'm such a
big legend of zelda fan but if there's
anything that's going to get me on board
for the N axis Zelda game what do you
think ty
I think it's gonna happen like I've been
saying it since last year I'm like yeah
well cell does not coming out this year
so I guess they must be pushing it for
the NX you know or whatever you know
code name because how are you gonna sell
that console after people invested so
much in the wii u like what's gonna get
you to buy an annex yeah it's just help
and the weird thing is it sounds like
the annex isn't going that well we don't
know anything yeah but it sounds like it
might not be a traditional console so
then how do you launch a game like zelda
which is this very traditional game
which you've been developing for the wii
u which is relatively you know
traditional console if you've got this
crazy concept console it's gonna have
like this you know mobile and like couch
versions or like dichotomy happening
then do you want the game that is like
the big platform for that big pusher to
be like basically just a zelda game like
it doesn't i wonder if they'd have to go
back and reinvent it a bit as well so
that's why I worry maybe we'll make it I
guess we'll have to find out those know
you think in the comments is a bunch
more games i want to get through here as
well will we see the last guardian come
at eric i'm gonna go with no no 4 2016
no i think mike i don't think either
know if anything like december okay okay
so let's say a late push let's see ah i
gonna love these together because
they're that's the yeah that's you yeah
back on crazy yeah yes yes they're both
dark to both tom clancy games that are
boat ubisoft games okay the division
Ghost Recon wildlands ubisoft can't
possibly put I two games in one year
which 1d thing comes out I don't think
there's a date for wild lands by the way
I'm just guessing maybe next year
division this year for sure sometime
even if it gets pushed back I think it's
been through a beta now that like not
everyone got invited to but like you're
like on their forums and whatnot you
might have got an invite we saw some
leaked stuff it's got push gently a
couple times to yak Robin which back yet
but I'm pretty sure at some point that
game will come out in the Badlands
probably next year because you can't do
two in one year hmm I i agree i would
say division has to come out this year i
mean we've it's been delayed what twice
now yeah and difficult delays to not
like yeah and we actually seen a decent
you know like a lot of it durably they
introduced that whole like you can screw
over your team at the end at yeah but
then they showed wild lands right after
that or at least in the same you know
same press conference and wild lands
looks great but
there's no way because we haven't seen
anything else from that if one of the
two has come it's gonna be division and
it seems like it's time for because
we've been waiting for how long now may
be a good thing though cuz we didn't
wait too long for watchdogs and i ended
up being a big disappointment yeah
couple more one to run through XCOM 2
that's gonna come out you don't think
it'll be pushed back past it's uh no I
think it's februari physics are ya okay
um for honor I feel like I haven't seen
enough of that game I played a bit of a
but I want to play I still haven't
played it it's my fault I should play at
PSX um there's a lot of interest because
it's are like number one game I think I
whole like really at gamespot 50 it's
our number one game it looks super
scientist abated yeah it looks super
interesting I'm kind of curious about
what the like is it like you pay forty
dollars for the game sixty dollars with
game is it like a free to play with like
a you know like a freemium model with
like skins and stuff like that who knows
it didn't it looked pretty done I mean
like what are you what else do we need
more maps and other like rice and maybe
less I don't think there's a single
player I don't know they're just kind of
look like a like a new age jewelry but
yeah cuz I can be a social sharing the
new ice M&A yeah you know samurai Gunn
all right two more i'm gonna split these
up for you my heart yet doom is it
coming out this year yeah i could see a
comment fall yeah it's uh the
multiplayer seem pretty polish from what
I played yeah it felt really good as I
embargoes no no no I don't know about
that yeah no no it's not all right this
was a while ago good thing it's not find
out and last one horizon zero dawn oh
man I want it to keep showing that same
I know a name like kind of T Rexy
dinosaur like just kind of killed in a
slightly different way or in a like
slightly different area ah man I I don't
think so mmm but uh I think III will be
telling like maybe if the demo is
actually there then maybe like you for
but yeah especially cuz it's acquitted
like a second party kind of thing as
well because it's gorilla and I feel
like Sony always give them time so we'll
have to wait and see thank you gentlemen
for letting us know what you think is
going to be delayed what we already know
is delayed in 2016 let us know what you
think you think you think is going to be
delayed in 2016 in the comments below
and this time because it's the new Lobby
we're going to read them and talk about
them
next week so stick your thoughts in the
comments below and Zelda especially yea
or nay let us know